وأنا كتارا لست لاعباً رئيسياً
في أوبك ولكنه يأتي في وقت
تتعرض فيه هذه المنظمة لضغوط
لزيادة إنتاجها ، ألق نظرة على
أسعار النفط اليوم جورج لأنك
سترى أنها أعلى بكثير من
النفط الخام وغرب تكساس الوسيط.  بنسبة 5 ٪ ، هناك الآن الكثير
من هذا في الواقع لا يتعلق بهذه
الأخبار لأنه على الرغم من انسحاب القط
من أوبك وكان عضوًا منذ عام
1961 ، إلا أن الأخبار الكبيرة من الناحية السياسية ليست في
الواقع كما قلت لاعبًا كبيرًا في
النفط وفي الواقع  من
المثير للاهتمام أن تأتي هذه الأخبار من مجموعة العشرين خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، حيث رأينا أن المملكة
العربية السعودية وروسيا يبدو أنهما على استعداد
لمواصلة التعاون لتقليل النفط في
السوق ، ولهذا السبب نرى
تحركًا نفطيًا كبيرًا اليوم ، ولكن هذه الأخبار شديدة جدًا
مثيرة للاهتمام من الناحية السياسية ، وجاءت هذه الأخبار
على أنها مفاجأة ، أود أن
أقولها اليوم في السطر العلوي من
المؤتمر الصحفي القطري الذي عقدناه من
التغريدات التي نشرناها اليوم هو أن قطر
تريد التركيز أكثر على الغاز الطبيعي ،
أي من  بالطبع هو سوق أكبر بكثير ،
لذا فأنت لا تشير بالضبط
إلى الأهمية الاقتصادية داخل تلك
الكتلة ولكن سياسيًا ورمزيًا
ماذا يعني هذا خاصة
فيما يتعلق بالتوترات آنا
بين السعودية وقطر ، أعتقد أن
هذه التوترات لديها الكثير لتلعبه
من حيث  في إطار أوبك
الذي تعرفه بحكم الأمر الواقع بقيادة المملكة
العربية السعودية ، أعتقد أن قطر كانت تشعر
بالعزلة المتزايدة الآن ، ولا
تزال تفرض حظرًا على السفر والتجارة
من قبل المملكة العربية السعودية من قبل الإمارات العربية المتحدة من
قبل البحرين وهذا بسبب
مزاعم بأن  إنها تدعم الإرهاب
بسبب صلاتها الوثيقة بإيران بحيث
تستمر في التصفية ،
وبالإضافة إلى ذلك ، لديك لاعب من خارج أوبك مثل
روسيا يلعب في هذا المزيج الذي لديه
سيطرة أكبر بكثير داخل
أوبك أيضًا ، لذا يمكنك أن ترى في هذه الخطوة
بالإضافة إلى جورج.  عليك أن تنظر
محليًا ، لقد أجرى تعديلاً وزاريًا كبيرًا
مؤخرًا ، يرى الكثيرون أن وزير الطاقة الجديد في
القمة كان أكثر
عدوانية  لذا ربما لا
يكون الأمر مفاجئًا نظرًا لما
حدث في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر